anytime you have
especially in a place like that where
you have like auctions and things like
that in cash the Mafia is involved they
UKUSA so you there's a big Yakuza
presence just in the neighboring village
of Taiji which would make me think they
probably have their fingers in the
dolphin export business as well
a coozer Yakuza that's the Japanese
mafia they're the ones after these guys
full coverage full body tattoos okay
thank you guys they're all built on
what's called an onsen which is like a
natural hot spring every hotel there is
built on top of one and there's like you
go down this room and sit in the spring
but they all have signs like no tattoos
which I even have tattoos a couple and I
get problems there clearly I'm not you
cuza but those signs are meant for
Yakuza they don't want the Mafia guys
hanging out in the steam rooms really or
everywhere down there you see them
everywhere have you guys had any run-ins
with those guys personally not Yakuza so
to speak but we have they have an ultra
right wing there which would be like hmm
our version of like you know like maybe
like the proud boys are like neo-nazis
that hang out or like that they're like
that and they even dress similar they'll
dress in like high watered pants that
are really tight with a button-down
shirt
shaved head like skinheads that kind of
dress up and they show up and they're
prone to violence and their although
they're the kind of stuff like one thing
they do all the time is they drive with
a truck with like a speaker on the top
that looks like it's from like the 60s
like a giant Bell the most massive
speaker you ever seen on the roof of
their band yeah we're there and they'll
just go back and forth in front of our
hotel for like 20 hours a day like as
loud as they can like go home Oh Barry
like shouting threats and like wow when
The Cove was shown for like a week in
just a couple theaters in Japan they
found out who the mother is of the owner
of the distributor that bought the cove
and they went to her house and
surrounded it and banged on all the door
and windows and like shook her house it
was it was a distributor the the country
but when the cocaine out heating this
distributor Japan bought the rights to
the cove and it only showed for like a
week in like two theaters but they went
and like threatened his family with
violence Wow that is insane whether
they're doing it on their own or whether
that they're just an arm of a bigger
operation a Yakuza operation is telling
that they're the arm that goes out and
handle suit like that it's stuff like
that you know I don't right you see it
there it's not you know it's not
something I'm making up you the Mokka is
a clear presence down there and now does
just a whale meet in Japan from all the
whales they catch does that have high
levels of mercury like dolphin - yes
okay and now you'll find like when you
go to Tokyo you'll find specialty
restaurants that you know maybe a few in
Tokyo specialty places where you can buy
whale meat and in Taiji of course where
the dolphin hunt is there's tons of
places there that specialize it and in
fact you'll see tour buses coming every
week or filled with old people that are
taking a specific like whale eating tour
from a neighboring big city
they'll come six hours by bus to go to
three different restaurants that
specialize in whale meat and sushi and
stuff like that because they have some
connection to it because after the war
there they had that's what they had to
eat and you know that ins connection so
it's really an older generation on its
own whaling would die out like whaling
is completely subsidized by the
government it loses so much you know I
think forty million dollars or something
it loses every year and the government
puts money into it to prop it up and
what it is you know you said is you know
they blame they blame overfishing on the
Dolphins it's pest control it's there's
plenty of dolphins whatever excuse to
those excuses always change what it
really boils down to is whaling is kind
of the last vestige and it's like it's
their final thing of like you know we're
armed because after the war we basically
the United States we ran
Japan we told him you can't have an army
you can't do this this is how you're
gonna have to now live and to be part of
their society because they were outcasts
after World War two and so it's one of
the last like things are holding on to
like you're not gonna no one's gonna
tell us to stop doing this cuz it none
of it makes sense the whole whaling
thing that they have to put money into
it no one's eating it right put it into
schools to try to get young kids to
interested in it and you know fact is
full of mercury every part of it is bad
then last stubborn vestige of
materialism like you're not then you you
know you're not the big United States
isn't going to tell us what to do